man demons that was on me bad situations
happened i had a very bad situation with
a female
and that was the end of it for me like i
man like [ __ ] i was suicidal even at a
young age like i got a when i was like
10 years old
younger than that probably like eight
years old i put a blade on my wrist
it's just [ __ ] that i was going through
when i was young like just seeing [ __ ]
being around you grew up where minnesota
saint paul minnesota yeah tell me about
how you grew up
okay so uh you know from a small town st
paul minnesota uh twin cities
uh what we call it you know uh money
soda some people call it like that uh
yeah born in the 80s you know crack baby
but uh yeah like just similar [ __ ] like
most cities around the world man you
know you got similar [ __ ] everywhere
uh you know gun violence and gangs and
all that type of [ __ ] but you know like
i tell people it's just you got more or
less of it you know different places
different places you go
um
but yeah [ __ ]
young man i i've seen a lot of [ __ ] man
a lot of a lot of things i've seen i
probably shouldn't have seen been
witness to
uh exposed to raised around a lot of
dope fiends and alcoholics
you know i i seen some of my uncles beat
to death and you know they didn't die
but you know they was bloodied up and
stabbed and all kind of [ __ ] man like
that uh uh my my brother
stepbrother he passed or he died was
killed shot in the head uh at 17 years
old a week before his 18th birthday you
know that and that really had a very
harsh impact on me you know being that
young i think i was probably about 11
years old
and uh you know he died gang banging
[ __ ] [ __ ] you know what i'm saying
[ __ ] with the gang's tough
uh from 90s 9-0 [ __ ] you know i had some
other cousins relatives that was from
six-fold they were 60s crips you know
hoosters
you know was your dad in your life my
dad yeah he is now he was he was
absolutely earlier on um
you know that that's it that's a whole
nother story my dad he you know he was
kind of a known gangster in the town
uh where i come from so
you know that kind of it opened a lot of
doors for me young early on
and um
yeah just
yes
i remember one time when i was young i
probably i know maybe
five or six years old he owned a
building
and uh some people got shot outside the
building you know and uh allegedly he
allegedly you know he had something to
do with it
but um i i went downstairs you know
outside and i seen after i heard all the
noise and i was young man and i you know
and i seen it it was just blood
everywhere it's crazy [ __ ] right
and i think about a lot of this stuff
today like a lot of experiences that i
had in the game a lot of things that i
went through a lot of things i wouldn't
have seen and heard and just my family
and [ __ ] like that man it's just
it it it weighed on me heavy mentally so
so you got into the game
at what age
uh i was about 20
20 21.
who introduced you to that
nobody really introduced me it was more
of an opportunity i seen movies and was
influenced by it you saw the gang life
wasn't for you
yeah exactly
and um and that's another option right
so so i you know i moved i came to vegas
and and fell into it
fell into it man uh
but i had a lot of bad situations
going through this [ __ ] man i
was hurting a lot of people
um there's women i remember a time
and i i i was so mad at this chick man
beat her up beat her up real bad
and kicked out the car took her shoes
took her purse all the money she had
nothing on her kicked out on a
[ __ ] freeway man
and it was just you know time after time
you know beating a woman up
uh [ __ ] at the house
she tried to try to say some slick [ __ ]
man and run off on me you know run into
the bathroom slam the door
and uh you know i punched a hole in the
bathroom dope man and grabbed and pulled
it through that [ __ ] man
and and i was stomping on her and [ __ ]
man
it was it was it was a bad situation
but the worst the worst situation of all
men was when i beat this this woman up
and i hit her with like a baton
and uh she has so much blood on the side
of her head man her whole hair you know
she was blind man and all her whole side
of her [ __ ] was bloodied up there's
blood on her shirt and all that [ __ ] man
it was it was it was it was horrific man
it was bad
it was a real bad a brutal beating man
and um
that really affected me a lot
that really affected me a lot
and just doing doing things like that
and like i said people [ __ ]
dying from
from [ __ ] that i've been a part of like
the game you know and
man
were drugs as part of your life oh yeah
man [ __ ] i was a [ __ ] i i looked
like i was a [ __ ] dope fiend man [ __ ]
you know we partied all the time man
snorting blow man
popping pills and [ __ ] getting drunk all
the time
you know i just had money to support my
habit so hell yeah man [ __ ] good time
having a lot of fun and [ __ ] man uh
yeah a lot a lot of lot a lot a lot of
[ __ ] drugs man a lot of drugs
a lot of drugs
but uh and that kind of behavior with
women is that something you learned from
your family or where where oh yeah that
[ __ ] was in the household it was it was
in the household for sure you know a lot
a lot of fights a lot of violence and
stuff a lot of arguments and stuff you
know stepfather from my real father and
[ __ ] i seen a lot of a lot of that
hands-on my dad actually took a shot he
took shots at my mom
you know uh
he thought that she had something to do
with one of his cars one of his cars got
blew up
in front of his house and he thought she
had something to do with it man
took shots at her you know
i i'm sure you wanted to kill her
so you know like i said we
we normalized a lot of [ __ ] from
things that we see from you know from
parents and friends society what male
role models do you have as a kid
male role
models aside uh
a side of the with the music [ __ ] really
was just
it's like rappers and [ __ ] man that was
really like you know and then there was
a few pips
you know some pimps that you know really
from from american the dvds and [ __ ] man
that really turned me on to the game you
know i was on fire for the game
you know really really wanted to be a
part of that [ __ ] and uh i had dope
money and [ __ ] moved to vegas and bought
some property and [ __ ]
i seen the game my eyes were big than a
[ __ ] man when i was out there i
was in vegas seeing guys riding around
and benzes and [ __ ] man and
uh custom rolls royces and [ __ ] man all
that i hey eyes blew up like a
[ __ ] man i was turnt on by that
[ __ ]
and i wanted to get down and uh and i
got down
but it was it was it was tough in the
beginning i i was easy easily knocking
[ __ ] but you know figuring out a
space and how
finding my pimp space really you know
where i can really hide know knowing how
to move and wiggling the [ __ ] man and
how to manage and house these
[ __ ] [ __ ] and [ __ ] man
dealing with all these these
[ __ ] what we call headaches man
you know what i mean dealing with these
[ __ ] headaches you know i think
the most deep at one point in time i was
about four deep
at one point in time uh
you know and i lived in different places
i lived in [ __ ] uh texas arizona and
vegas at the same time at one point in
time in my pimp career
and uh
yeah so it was just
just [ __ ] on top of [ __ ] man but it
sounds like you had the awareness that
maybe this wasn't the right thing to be
doing oh yeah for sure the whole time
uh i can't say the whole time
because you know in the beginning of it
it was a lot of fun you know it was a
lot of fun the pimp game was fun not
convincing you know it especially in
vegas you know it's a different culture
in uh
in other places and [ __ ] but in vegas
you know we call it the blade you know
outside other places at the track but in
vegas it was the blade and uh it looked
it it was it was a glamour more
glamorous
for
the whole just the whole ambiance of the
[ __ ] you know we use casinos and [ __ ]
the likes you know what i mean we feel
like celebrities in this [ __ ] man you
know
it felt like real celebrities in the
game is is the
the poverty in the broken families that
these men and women grow up in
the the the reason that
the game is so
strong in the hood
yeah hey i mean like i said it's a way
you know people be hungry man my [ __ ]
starving people be broke
it's a survival
uh yeah natural mechanism and a survival
tactic man just trying to make way for
you know a better way
and uh i mean a lot of it's through
manipulation you know i've manipulated a
lot of women man i had a lot of women
that was doing things that uh not not
concerning about their health not
concerned about their safety you know
just get my money you know and that was
kind of the road i played in the game at
uh you know a lot of times in my career
this [ __ ] uh just getting my money i
didn't give a [ __ ] what the [ __ ] was
doing or what she did i i was a uh
influence on this [ __ ] you know a lot of
times i influenced a lot of these broads
to do the things that they did
you know and uh just luckily that no one
was really hurt i mean i had a situation
where there was a woman
um
you know well
a couple situations you know we don't
really call it it ain't really rape in
the sense of that uh being in the game
they just kind of stole the [ __ ] from
them you know what i mean uh but a lot
of rapes happen and [ __ ] man i had to
tighten up on my game so that [ __ ]
didn't happen and that kind of that
affected me when women were starting to
get they was getting raped but you know
in the game you can't show no weakness
and those you can't be that you know
like you saw for whatever man and
showing like concern to the woman like
that and just kind of had to stay hard
on her you know so she kept doing what
she did didn't want her to get into you
know
the mind state where she's feeling bad
for herself and all that [ __ ] now [ __ ]
this is this part of this [ __ ] this is
part of the game this is how it should
go man the game can be vicious man
real vicious
you know a lot of women a lot of a lot
of people died in this [ __ ] man [ __ ]
around and [ __ ]
in these streets
yeah but then at some point you'd turn
the corner
oh yeah for sure i had no choice
i had no choice because either that or
you know like i started i was going to
jail left and right different situations
and scenarios and [ __ ] and uh
yeah i had to change my life man
because i would have ended up you know
probably [ __ ] dead
[ __ ] in prison for sure
i was headed that way
i was headed to prison for sure you know
it was the prison time for a pimp
nowadays is long oh man it's a hell of a
lot worse man you know it's not a lot
worse it's not 5 10 years [ __ ] no i mean
with this human trafficking and all this
[ __ ] man they can they can trump up so
many charges on the [ __ ] man you be
looking at [ __ ] 100 years man you
know and it's it's it's crazy that way
you know it's a lot different because i
remember i don't know how it is now but
i remember [ __ ] texas i think was
probably one of the only states that
pimping was a misdemeanor
you know it wasn't a felony like it is
in most places it was it was a [ __ ]
misdemeanor
you know a lot a lot of people get away
with a lot of [ __ ] down here but uh
you know nah man i was just fortunate
that i caught my
my my pimp case in california at that
time and when i caught the case
uh
[ __ ]
i they they put it was a d.a reject man
i got caught up in it and it was a weird
it was a kind of a funny situation how i
got caught up
out here and uh when they knocked me and
i was like one foot in one foot out so i
wasn't really sharp on my p's and [ __ ]
i'm getting drunk
getting high and all that [ __ ] man
[ __ ] up a lot of times
and i got caught slipping man and uh and
they knocked me took all the money i had
all this [ __ ] man i was [ __ ] up
and yeah you were in with the
the top of the name players in the game
right oh yeah for sure for sure yeah
yeah a lot of you're friends with bishop
and
yeah
yeah pk that's hey i'm calling right now
that's my you know that
pimpy ken was like you know og to me
like an uncle and you know used to have
long conversations with him all the time
man uh would be on the highway cross
country whatever he's doing what he's
doing and i was doing what i was doing
did those guys show you the ropes at all
when you're getting started
uh i mean naturally you know you got a
young pee around or talking to you yeah
they're gonna give you some game you
know they're gonna tell you some [ __ ]
and feed you some good information some
advice and [ __ ] some a lot of this [ __ ]
be kind of like [ __ ] you know
you know yeah don't save your money man
you know a lot of people you say that
you got to campaign it man don't save
your money for what what you say to your
money folk man you know what i mean blow
that [ __ ] man it's on a [ __ ] man it's
on the whole you know
get some oat you know it was that type
of that type of energy i got from a lot
of a lot of pimps man a lot of them a
lot of og pimps some of them are not
pimpy ken you know he stays on this [ __ ]
but someone i meant vegas man you know
it was always in between hoes man they
pimped on y'all a lot of the young ones
man you know i'm in between [ __ ] paid
right now man you know let me get a jug
that type of [ __ ] jiggy to death man
was there one event that
helped you change your ways
[ __ ] it's like i said when i there's a
whole series of events
it it was
a series of events but the one really
was with the female
that uh it was it was brutal and i heard
guys that beat women to death and
actually killed him like i had a friend
he killed he killed a woman in the hotel
man you know frustrated dealing with
drugs and [ __ ] man he was smoking pcp i
tried that [ __ ] when we used to [ __ ]
around and get high up that [ __ ] man
dipping in my [ __ ] uh we dipped our
blunts and [ __ ] and smoked that [ __ ]
uh man a man tripped out man and he
killed he ended up killing a woman and
getting on a high speed with the police
and shoot out and he ended up getting
killed
so i mean it's just a lot of different
things like that a lot of guys that died
in this [ __ ] man
and uh
and i i just i thought about that type
of [ __ ] in in a direction i was headed
on and the things that i was doing
because i didn't give a [ __ ] about a lot
of [ __ ]
i didn't give a [ __ ]
i remember being on the track one time
on figaro man you know i'm thirsty
hungry like the weirwood for england why
to write them off like two powder white
doughnuts man you know trying to have me
one you know right
uh brand new range rover humping rims
all the [ __ ] shining you know what i
mean uh mashing you know
i pull up i see a [ __ ] man uh i'm way
deep past 100 blocks on fig
[ __ ] told me don't ride over there
don't ride over there pete but i ended
up going anyway uh
she pulled over you know what i'm saying
jump out
on the ditch whatever you know probably
my [ __ ] throw my cars in the air
whatever she wasn't paying me no my
[ __ ] wiggled off and [ __ ] man head down
uh spent off on me but as i'm backing up
walking back to the car mind you this is
three four o'clock in the morning i'm
past 100 blocks and fig and uh you know
as i'm turning around it's dark as a
[ __ ] right i hear hey
uh man my heart almost dropped man i'm
about to piss off myself man i was
scared to the [ __ ] man hey man i
turn around i see i see two [ __ ] man
one of them had a gun on them you know
what i'm saying hey one of these had a
gun on like ap pimps don't get out all
the cars around here man they don't hey
they are me
and then one of the guys man he tapping
he said hey peter [ __ ] from the movie
man
he's like what's up young man so we
shake it up top it up and [ __ ] man they
really hey hey they gave me a pass man
even though i was hella out of bounds
disrespectful you know what i'm saying
all in [ __ ] neighborhoods that i
didn't because they remember you from uh
yeah from from the dvds and [ __ ] the
documentary films and [ __ ] i was i
played a part in and i was on a lot of
different documentaries and [ __ ] uh for
my game got some trophies and [ __ ] like
i said so so today you're you're married
with uh the square life man like a
[ __ ] man happy square man hip
square you know yeah
you're happier this way
yeah yeah i mean it's it's a little
boring you know it's a little boring at
times because you know hey man life was
action-packed you know every day was the
drama was hey man the drama i hear this
from so many people i interviewed that
they're addicted to the the drama of the
streets yeah man it's it's it's a it's a
drug in itself man as kenny says no
kenny red says nobody's getting rich in
the game
it's hard to unless you got other [ __ ]
you do some smart moves and [ __ ] it's
only a few man only a few [ __ ]
really slipped through the cracks of
this [ __ ] man that really win about this
game but other than that just a whole
lot of memories a lot of good times a
lot of ups and downs in this [ __ ] man
you know you're gonna fall
you know you're gonna fall man
you know you're gonna find yourself hey
man i've been homeless at times in the
you know in the game
you know [ __ ] up broke scraping the
ground you know
uh and you know had to dig myself up out
of that them holes that i was in and
[ __ ] man
how many years you've been out
uh
see
i would say 10 about 10 years because i
i can't consider myself pimping some of
the years that i had a [ __ ] that was
paying me i don't consider that pimping
man just because i had a woman that gave
me some money that was doing whatever
she was doing hauling or whatever that
wasn't pimping to me because i was
raised in the game around oh geez and
[ __ ] man that uh you know they look
it was a different it was different
pimping you know i wouldn't i was a
spoiled boyfriend at one point in time
in my career and [ __ ] that's what a
swell boyfriend hey man hey spoiled
boyfriend like a [ __ ] man that's
great it's a lot of guys they spoil
boyfriends they not pimps man they not
p's
you know i don't understand why they
want to associate themselves just be you
you know be who you is man if you got
only fans girls doing doing doing that
[ __ ] man hey hey man pay your taxes do
that you know what i mean don't
it's not pimping you know because you're
not
you're not affiliated with what's your
biggest regret in your life
uh just man
just not being in my kid's life
just not being in my kid's life
uh earlier on you know i was i was
[ __ ] deadbeat man deadbeat like a
[ __ ] i didn't care i
my second born
uh i would say three i was in jail at
the time when she was born but when i
got out of jail uh i stayed around i was
around for about three months and i
shook man
i should i didn't even think twice about
it it's [ __ ] up i think about that
[ __ ] i didn't even think twice about
leaving
my child
you know
and that [ __ ] [ __ ] with me
you know a lot and uh like i said hey
i'm married now man having another one
and uh you can do it right this time
oh yeah like a [ __ ] and i mean
to read and i didn't get there was no
there was no plan to get married and no
[ __ ] like that kind of was something
that you know i was still gaming even
though i was out the game i was not a
game you know but uh you know i fell
into a situation met a meta chick or
whatever and uh you know while i was
dealing going through my transition in
the life man and figuring a new space
out uh we we had some some interesting
conversation and i talked to her and and
the conversations that we had was was
healing man
you know i needed that and she talked to
me in a way that no one ever talked to
me before in my life and and it helped
me a lot
like
i i was teary-eyed man
and a lot of the conversations that we
had man and it helped me get through
that the hardest times in my life man i
wanted to kill myself you know like i
said man i was probably eight years old
man look i got a [ __ ] scar on
my wrist right here man i put a blade on
my [ __ ] man from some of the [ __ ] that i
was around when i was a kid and then
being in the game and [ __ ] that i was
going through in the game and [ __ ] i was
doing i was just looking in the mirror
and i was like kind of like disgusted in
myself and just looking at who i became
and and just thinking about a lot of
things that i did it was just
it [ __ ] me up
you know it [ __ ] me up mentally
and like i said she she healed me from a
lot of that [ __ ] and i was able to get
through that
you know that's great man like a
[ __ ] man
like a [ __ ]
you know young what would you say is the
most important thing you've learned in
your life
most important thing i learned in my
life or just in the game either way
uh i am the game let's talk about the
game right okay so uh
uh
in the game a lot of a lot of people and
i would consider myself one of those
people right because while i was a gang
the pimping wasn't really that wasn't
really something that i really wanted to
do with my life
and i learned that there's a lot of
people that just
attach themselves to names and
characters
you know because they think it's cool
something to do
and that's why i deal with a lot of [ __ ]
so one of the most important things i
learned is
to not follow something that's trendy or
try to be something that i'm not and try
to be play a [ __ ] role or a
character that that's not me
you know what i mean i fell into that a
lot
you know and it was easy to get in
character man hey i'll do some [ __ ] up
[ __ ] you know just to prove a point
just to prove a point i
would do some [ __ ] up [ __ ] man
hurts and hurt a [ __ ] brother
you know
you know there was there's one chick out
[ __ ]
at a hotel if this act like she didn't
want to [ __ ] open the door and i had
the chain on and [ __ ] man i'm beating on
a [ __ ] door beating on the door
she opens the door
but the chain was there man i grabbed
that [ __ ] arm you know start you know
pulling the [ __ ] door slamming
that [ __ ] [ __ ] you know i'm
sure i probably broke her [ __ ]
a wrist arm or something man uh pulling
putting on that [ __ ] door
because i was so mad and [ __ ] man i
wanted to kill that bro man
and a lot of the drugs and alcohol made
it easy for me to do that [ __ ]
and it just it made it it was like that
was the life that was my lifestyle man
it was it was influenced heavy by a lot
of the drugs
and alcohol
and i did it a lot of that [ __ ] you
clean now
i you know i i [ __ ] i'm in the truck i'm
in the trucking business so uh you know
we get hit with random uas and [ __ ] like
i said man the transition now life is
kind of boring man
life is boring like a [ __ ] man
you know uh
you know but i don't have a lot of the
problems i have to look over my shoulder
ain't got to worry about all that you
know that [ __ ] worry about the police
kicking in my dog man i had man [ __ ]
feds came one time i thought they was
coming for me i had a [ __ ] uh i just
knocked a [ __ ] she had her own crib and
[ __ ] i'm at the broad house and [ __ ]
probably about a couple of months had
about a 90 day run so far with her and
uh [ __ ] knocking at the door
you know who the [ __ ] is that you know
and uh then her phone starts she getting
phone calls she answered the phone and
she you know
she's talking it's federal agent
i'm scared to the [ __ ] my truck
outside you know right outside this
[ __ ] house man the fed is at the door
i'm thinking they're coming for me and
she tell me you know uh it's from a guy
she was dealing with out of florida and
[ __ ] man they was looking for him and
she dealt with them obviously she had
the same phone number
but uh he was on a run you know [ __ ]
week miners and [ __ ] man you know
[ __ ] with [ __ ] minors man
yeah
so [ __ ] up [ __ ] man [ __ ]
[ __ ] with kids you know like i said i
was a witness to seeing man uh you know
my one of my younger cousins and [ __ ] uh
you know his mom passed him around for
doping
you know
[ __ ] like that you know so
the game is
it's evil man
it's a lot of poison in the game
i mean i collected a lot of evil spirits
i feel like just
every time something happened it was
another demon i was
drawing these demons and [ __ ] man
and then you know like with
with the e pills man that was a
[ __ ] man that [ __ ] turned me
into a whole nother [ __ ] man
i was popping in [ __ ] like
crazy you know i had a drink i used to
make uh i crush them up put them in put
them in some uh some gray goose and
pineapple juice you know a little the
dough juice bottles crush up the peel
put it in there shake it up
and uh that's how i got my day started a
lot of times
and uh
sipping on that [ __ ] so i controlled it
it's like a way for me to control the
beast because if i just pop that [ __ ]
down that [ __ ] probably weaken the
[ __ ] but the end of my [ __ ]
boat
and the [ __ ] was really
stumped down about it though man real
serious grabbing [ __ ] putting on hair
and [ __ ] man just
you know
vicious
about that [ __ ]
it's a lot of fun though
all right young greg thank you so much
for sharing your story yeah all right
good luck with everything
you